هذه هي الحدود الجديدة للروبوتات التي
تساعد كبار السن على استخدام التكنولوجيا
للحفاظ على استقلاليتهم مع تقدمهم
في العمر في المنزل.
الرفيق الحقيقي وهذا يعني أن هذا
المنتج يحتاج إلى الشعور
وكأنه يمتلك عقلًا خاصًا به لمدة ست سنوات
من البحث الذي مكّن من تصميم الروبوتات
الحدسية لكبار السن الذين
قد لا يتم تبنيهم باستخدام
التكنولوجيا الروبوتية ولكنه يفعل أكثر بكثير من
المتحدثين الأذكياء مثل  اليكسا الذي
ينفذ الأوامر ببساطة يستمع ويستجيب بشكل
مختلف
ويتذكر ما يقوله الناس لك باستخدام
ذلك في المحادثات المستقبلية ويظهر
لهم أنك تقر بما قالوه
ويظهر لهم أنك تستمع وأخذ
ذلك في الاعتبار والتخطيط
للتفاعلات المستقبلية مع ذلك الشخص الذي
صمم المتحدث فيه  سان فرانسيسكو
وإسرائيل يضيء وجهه عند
إجراء محادثة يقدمها exer
الروتينية واللعب لألعاب التوافه
لتعزيز البراعة الجسدية والعقلية
ونعم أيضًا يخبر النكات بوجود
فجوة رعاية متنامية تواجه كبار السن
وعائلاتهم يحاول
heliq تزويد كبار السن المعزولين بحلول مثل
كيفية الوصول إلى موعد مع الطبيب.
حتى تتمكن العائلات من
رؤية كيف يفعل أحبائهم
الروبوتات الحدسية ، يقول ثلاثة أرباع
كبار السن في السبعينيات والثمانينيات من العمر كانوا قادرين
على إعداد Leq بمفردهم في خمس أو
عشر دقائق ، هناك تكلفة أولية تبلغ
مائتين وخمسين دولارًا بالإضافة إلى ثلاثين
دولارًا  رسم الاشتراك الشهري وداعا
الآن
أخبار ديفيد لويس ABC 7